how's it going ma'am - welcome back to
bully wake up in the morning feeling
like a bowl
get it bowl because bully hahahahahaha
I don't even know why I try I should
just just okay anyway rich quest you
bros wanna do today there's a lot of
them to choose from which one do you
wanna pick all right that one
sure sure why not why not why not I say
I'm a ball where is it it's in the oh
we're gonna do the jocks now we did the
greasers with did their [ __ ] we
didn't do them oh I like a ball hello
little friend it wasn't a ghost of all
I'm not a ball with the grey side where
the jobs we did the Nerds we didn't do
the job it's like the only ones we
haven't done hold it now that nail then
alright are we going to the gym I think
we're going to the gym yep
alright let's go ah face black oh yeah
we already did this one [ __ ] I'm so
stupid
alright we're gonna take down the
posters of our the girl our love
interest Oh Mandy I got what's up I
wasn't able to ball same joke twice good
job it why are boys so awesome
all right they're supposed to here I
hope we get to see it we do get to see
it are we gonna draw a penis on it if
you don't like it then you sure to draw
a penis on it if you don't like it then
you've heard about it you know can she
just tear it down does it really had to
censor it
no one cares anymore Greaseballs all
right there's apparently only two of
them but yeah there's enough for two
posters for all the school to notice I
know so my dance that is [ __ ]
disgusting ha ha ha ha you got
mayonnaise on your pants in front of a
picture like that ok
in public - that's [ __ ] nicely Aldi I
thought better of you why did I change
color was that really necessary stop it
oh there's more posters I'm not a pig
I'm a bull no no I don't want to go to
class ball grabber
I mean bull grabber all right here we go
why did they only care about me not
being in class they should be in class
too
oh there's a couple in town all right
let's go and get em bras
good thing my wife didn't see me looking
at bad good thing indeed some art hater
obvious he's not changing anything by
doing what what did he do the [ __ ] did
he do some art ager some porn hater okay
that's a funnel that gets the father for
everything you've done for us
alright let's go up here now that I shut
the police's there maybe I shouldn't
laugh pocket I'll sure he sees me I'm
spraying on a wall how is that asking
you on a date no it's not I don't think
so
what meet Mandy at the boy storm
alright cool I can do that come in a
vest by misty man who are your parents
it's me I'm just burying a mascot
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh hey Maddy I know
let's make out tell me who dad yeah yep
the weirdest kiss ever Amanda now likes
it that girl is so hard to flirt but so
easy at the same time all right um
nerds house or what do you bros wanna go
why do you want to go to class
ah fine best buy I'm sorry jack I better
go to class
here we go the big game ooh what is that
yes
candy from Ohio you would be a fair
queen for me what that little thong and
with those massive piles of second I
survey initially you'd think who's that
handsome stranger then I'd walk into the
bar what if I am i doing my Wahb pity
what my suave ability huh your swag my
way sighs I'd look up and say what's a
nice girl like you doing in a place like
this and you'd say take me to the hay
barn as' what's that you're eating
nothing nothing just some some history
homework what did I see it's personal
personal history sounds interesting
yes yes you wouldn't understand I think
I was anyway listen the big game is
today uh-huh operation Trojan cow is
ready to proceed operation Trojan cow my
name is name ever my spies have already
been gathering the information that will
bring about the downfall of the jocks at
this school so I'm killing them eating
this
does that mascot is awesome yes
rendezvous with my agents in the field
rendezvous we shall all right
Dan's in front of fat [ __ ] it's that
that you're pissing me off you know what
I'll give it that give it out that don't
you ever disrespect me fat dad let's get
ready to cower that kill there it's not
a cow dance that's a bull ban oh [ __ ]
nope Huawei whale David stop ain't no
yeah countdown successful talk to nerd
agents what the [ __ ] away huh okay oh
[ __ ] I have to dance uh get ready to cow
down say this david snabel
bam bam BHS whale dad doctor wonderous
amazing
thank you thank you so much thank you so
much alright what are they what the [ __ ]
are they Best Buy what are you doing
there okay what what do you want careful
patrols are everywhere we are in grave
danger at this very moment okay danger
of a knuckle sandwich if you don't get
on with it that's what here's a ball
we've rigged it to the set by the field
and swap it for the real game ball
although he looks by the way it's so
awesome alright
we are itching powder on the ball but
the rigged ball in the bag
uh doing it I like that they come on to
justice I do it she come this way
uh uh they're gonna edge odd so naughty
inception he doesn't even give a [ __ ]
I'm hotter here I blow his junk up what
the [ __ ] is going on
that's disgusting why would I dance for
you awesome
sandals I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] wet wedgie
Daniels wanker I'm I'm ball I'm aim Hey
[ __ ] I shouldn't even try all right
what's up here take this glue bottle
it's full of glue no [ __ ] Sherlock a
sticky situation on the team benches get
it sticky situation yeah I got I'm not
gay I'm not gonna do that
all right we got a good the bench it's
not I'm dancing I'm dancing get buck
[ __ ]
I got a big me up because I you can't
beat me up because I didn't do it go -
no let me glue this fast please okay
[ __ ] up let me grab my venture please
hold on a second what the [ __ ]
stop go away
let me do my quest thank you football
game will be good but not as good as the
wrestling match oh no my body stuck
funny joke
well at least he'd take it serious take
it in a nice way
alright more nerve agents apparently
over here what a weird [ __ ] quest
do-do-do-do no jump bag very sex tape
what's up algae still haven't zip your
pants huh
is it quit messing around before I lose
my patience and hurt you
No yeah poor algae okay here's the deal
the jocks keep their game sports drink
get a cooler go urinating it it Hansen
if you will what that's that's too far
man
no I think that's a little out of
control blowing up someone's junk yes
glowing their pants yes blowing up
someone's young heart sounds weird by
the way why does everyone wanna [ __ ]
dance I give you a dance alright yeah I
know it makes you excited Nikki okay
while sandal Jamin i'm follicle sassy
angelic i should join your squad you're
not getting a [ __ ] dance just you're
getting a beating so annoying oh Jesus
Christ has so much help cam dancing
dancing Jesus Christ
ain't no stay is staying up how awesome
are you happy countdown success I get
the [ __ ] out
studied right man
you don't paint someone's Gatorade that
ain't right
leave the school gym for poor boys I
know it was awesome it's a rumor that
someone's gonna screw up the game I'll
just have it to do much for me sounds
good
ah it's so weird all right last one
what the [ __ ] man urinated someone's
drink it's like pouring in someone's
salad your quest is perilous but the
rewards are glorious
alright what's the next thing no we're
sort of funny the first point time but
it's getting old now
no one's gonna notice that alright
marbles on the football field how do
they even work anyway they're just gonna
get pushed down they need to be a hard
surface you can't do it on a football
field do I really have to explain all
these things like Jace's Christ I don't
get it Geronimo yay all right that's
what
there we go dad we back up and there we
go
ah ah that's a stupid you won't even
[ __ ] work
but hey alright there's another one
apparently I don't even know why I tell
you what cuz it candies hey what's up
chess man but enough about me I don't
want to mess up those jocks straight to
business eh okay there's a switch box on
the school board on the field get to it
and switch it oh wow that sounds what
will it do it'll change the text of the
scoreboard i reprogrammed it you'll like
it
the jocks won't okay why the [ __ ]
wouldn't he just pulled the switch okay
finally we're doing the last quest of
this um I kind of failed the switch last
board because I didn't have enough
health but hey [ __ ] happens you have
been no that was mean I'm sorry I'm you
are awesome okay so many jocks
nobody [ __ ] dodge shut up shut up
alright what will this do get em guys
go what jocks play with their balls jugs
play with her ball they do play with
balls it's true I really I don't get I
don't get it
who is that kid yeah who really did kill
yay oh it's a little squid Hopkins my
name is mac women Murphy I did hockey
hey how did Hopkins what bother I've
abandoned everything he says and get on
with it
alright so it's a beating time oh [ __ ]
dodge two balls at ten throw picked them
up and throw them back at the jock
oh you want to play football you wanna
play football BAM yeah the only exploded
the header this is actually kind of
difficult like it's taken me a lot of
time there we go finally wanna Lance to
me I don't know [ __ ] on my ass
no [ __ ] on my ass but it hit my god a
bad
no it's gonna dad I'm gonna get you did
it pick up the ball let's see if I can
do it
BAM nyah let pain is good
stick up tough times even stalkers have
a gas now warm Jimmy I'll take you where
you're going to take out the team this
is your chance sack 10 how do i sack Ted
what is the side that's right who's
losers yeah yay yeah yeah what's up if
you did it you did it
I'm king of the [ __ ] hole you beat
them all and for everybody thanks for
your hand et oh this is gonna be great
hey Matt thanks for the help et you did
absolute so [ __ ] nothing
suddenly the king of the school what
that I never meant for things to turn
out this way
where's Jerry to control a couple of
psycho kids and be left alone while all
of them are psychically going to live
the good life
ye-yeah sorry is that dorky [ __ ] thought
I was being : [ __ ] the Fallen rise of
Jimmy Hopkins aged 15 chapter 5 shed
that does not seem like a like a good
chapter Hey I guess Garret a Jerry's
gonna come back what's up brother
H at home like yo it's Jimmy
I was going Jimmy oh hey I know you're
looking great great thank you it's all I
got to say I love that guy traitor bro P
hey Jimmy who's going on oh did it man I
took over this dump these morons are my
morons that's great just don't turn into
a jerk how could I Hey Baby how you
doing what you doing later let's
remember Jimmy not everybody likes you
correct they love me hey Gary yeah what
am I gonna get that twerp dude it's me
now I run this place and you're my
friend so please try to be cool oh man
you're bringing me down come on let's go
milk this thing for all it's worth we
might even find you a girl uh-huh no
that's impossible
Jimmy forgive me but I gotta go watch
hey what's going on hey what's going on
Jimmy I gotta go fine
all right so we're a cool and popular
NAB res how about that I never thought
that would happen
all right so we'll save here and it
seems like the last chapter is going on
right now it's a bit shame that this is
gonna end but hey now you're late all
right let me just say there I press like
and favorite if you enjoyed subscribe
come over tonight and I'll see you on
next episode all about me that beer Oh
I'm fat I have some [ __ ] hello check out
my job love huh